get this first I call her to say honey
we're re because I found out I was not
going to be dancing again so I said
honey where are you right now she said
I'm sitting on the runway in the plane
we're about to take off to come cheer
you on I said well I need you to save
the day
and she said I said no way well though
the whole thing was that I was on the
plane I had found out that she had
broken her arm and I was like oh I'm
still gonna come I'm gonna be there to
support her and I'm gonna be there to
take her to the hospital and everything
and I'm flying and I'm on the plane
about to take off like wheels are moving
and she calls me and she goes sailor I
found the silver lining yes I found the
I found the silver lining I was like
what you need me to stop at CBS like you
know like do you need anything anything
from home like bring the dog maybe and
she's like no you should go on Dancing
with the Stars and I was like no I'd
spent the summer like chillin with my
boyfriend and my dog and the Hamptons
like just sort of like I want your very
low-key ultimately came a good idea that
who was that you I thank her but
everybody kind of came up with the idea
at the same time cuz I like when
something really bad happens you got to
find the silver lining right and I
thought and you know it's uptown girl I
mean that's like my theme song and ever
since you know it can't just like be
anybody's got to be one of my girls I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this